hey everyone I'm a be sharp and welcome
to Abby's kitchen today we're going to
be talking about antioxidants we hear
the word all the time we know we should
be getting more of them but why are they
even important anyway well as I will
give you the old bio chemistry textbook
definition antioxidants are substances
that counter of the processes of
oxidation in the body and too much
oxidation is values their oxidation is
slaughtering the hind health issues like
cardiovascular disease cancer and of
course other chronic diseases and it's
also the same process involved in the
cut an apple and it turns brown I don't
know about you but I don't wanna look
like a brown rotten apple we accumulate
free radicals as a part of just normal
bodily processes but they can build up
in excess as a result of environmental
stressors like pollution x-rays sun
damage smoking or even too much clothes
looks the way free radicals do their
damage is by carrying around one or more
unpaired electrons which makes them very
unstable and the only way to stabilize
themselves is by stealing an electron
from an otherwise healthy cell which
makes them a free radical so then that
free radical needs to steal an electron
from another healthy cell it's like a
cascade effect as zombie apocalypse in
your body who is gonna save the day in
confidence antioxidants are like little
helmets for healthy cells that protect
them from getting oxidized by free
radicals it's also the same reason why
lemon juice prevent your apples from
turning brown lemon juice contains
antioxidants in our body the help to
neutralize free radicals by donating an
electron and in turn become oxidized
themselves but don't worry they're
stable in either form so even when
oxidized they're not bad for us however
as students
antioxidants become oxidized we need to
replenish the supply so this is why just
eating one orange a week is not good at
it I know it sounds complicated but
thankfully just getting your 7 to 10
daily servings of colorful fruits and
vegetables will supply you with loads of
antioxidant power one of my favorite
ways to get my fix especially in the
summertime is with my wild blueberry
pomegranate and lemonade collectives
this recipe features three major hits of
antioxidants from the lemons of
pomegranates and our star our wild
blueberries each wild blueberry is
packed with proanthocyanidins and
anthocyanins with more antioxidant power
in a half cup serving than almost any
other fruit with all that good stuff
going on research consistently links
them to a reduced risk of Parkinson's
disease cardiovascular disease various
cancers and symptoms of metabolic
syndrome they're also bigger friendly
and a great locale summer treat with a
whopping 400 berries clocking in at
around 45 calories so I first heat one
and a half cups of frozen wild
blueberries with a teaspoon of lemon
juice and one and a half tablespoons of
honey over medium heat until it bubbles
thickens and gets GMP divided the wild
blueberries between eight popsicle molds
and pop it into the freezer for at least
one to three hours meanwhile mix
together three quarters of a cup of
freshly squeezed lemon juice with one
and a half cups of water and three
tablespoons of honey over medium heat
until dissolved these lemons are packed
with antioxidants like flavonoids and
vitamin C and make a delicious tart
contrast to the sweet wild blueberries
so let's set that aside until it's cool
next I pour the lemonade over the frozen
blueberry layer and throw in about two
teaspoons each of pomegranate seeds not
only do these pomegranate seeds offer a
delicious
textural pop but these babies pack some
serious antioxidant power thanks to
their vitamin C and tannic polyphenols
finally I just pop in some wooden sticks
fries everything overnight to enjoy a
delicious and nutrient-rich treat do you
have a burning nutrition and food
question leave me a comment below and be
sure to answer it in an upcoming video
thanks so much for watching we're great
ways to get loads of nutrients this year
be sure to subscribe to my channel and
I'll see you next time on Abby's kitchen
so today I'm going to show you my top
tips for making delicious locale
cocktails as well as three ears this to
a recipes that will have you feeling
great and having fun all summer long
first up my Pinot Grigio melon ball
spritzer spritzers are a great way to
stretch flavor and calories of your
favorite white wine in refreshing summer
drink
you